dann herzlich willkommen zu meinem
Vortrag ich freue mich dass Sie da sind
der Beitrag den ich zum diesjährigen
Symposium grenzüberschreitende Lehre
leisten möchte formuliert eine
philosophische Perspektive auf unser
Thema
philosophisch bedeutet dabei dass ich
mich auf die Begriffe konzentrieren
werde mit denen sich das Grenzen
überschreiten beschreiben lässt ganz
konkret geht es mir um den Begriff der
Lehrer Persönlichkeit auf den ich
aufmerksam machen möchte weil ich in ihm
ein notwendiges Kriterium vermute um
Grenzen gleichsam sinnvoll als auch
effektiv zu überschreiten
zwar ist die Perspektive auf Begriffe
primär immer theoretisch aber es geht
mir dabei um etwas sehr praktisches denn
ich denke dass in dem Einnehmen dieser
Perspektive das Potenzial für die
Planung und Umsetzung konkreter
Grenzüberschreitungen in
Unterrichtssituationen liegt
in den folgenden Minuten möchte ich
jetzt weiß ich nicht wie ich ah ja
wunderbar in den folgenden Minuten
möchte ich zwei Fragen stellen und jeder
darauf antworten erstens welche Grenzen
sollen wir in der Lehre versuchen zu
überschreiten und warum und zweitens
warum stellt die Lehrer Persönlichkeit
für das Überschreiten von Grenzen ein
notwendiges Kriterium dar
ich beginne mit der ersten Frage nach
den Grenzen die in der Ankündigung
angesprochenen Grenzen wurden in
kategorisierenden in Teilen
gegensätzlichen Begrifflichkeiten
lokalisiert die Beispiele dazu habe ich
noch mal mitgebracht analog digital
synchron asynchron frontal interaktiv
Lehrenden und Studierenden zentriert das
grenzüberschreitende Moment wurde in
eben jenen Phänomen verortet die dadurch
zustande kommen dass sie das ehemals
getrennte in Beziehung bringen und so
neue kreative Möglichkeiten für die
Lehre entstehen
es war von Hybriden Unterrichtsmethoden
die rede ich habe noch ergänzt für
synchron und asynchron des Blended
Learning was natürlich auch ein bisschen
mehr umfasst für frontal interaktiv sind
mir vor allen Dingen technische Tools
eingefallen die man integrieren kann wie
zum Beispiel participi und für Lernenden
und studierendenzentriertheit das
inverted classroom Modell das heute
morgen schon mal vorgestellt wurde oder
erwähnt wurde
genau von diesen Beispielen ausgehen
möchte ich nun über die Art von Grenzen
nachdenken welche wir im Unterricht
versuchen sollten zu überschreiten und
nach dem Grundfragen warum wir das
überhaupt versuchen sollten
die Beispiele zeigen dass die
angesprochenen Grenzen die Art des
Lehrens betreffen also die konkreten
Methoden die bewusst gewählte
Unterrichtsgestaltung dadurch lässt sich
zunächst einmal festhalten dass die
Grenzüberschreitungen die hier
artikuliert werden nicht auf eine
allgemeine Aufhebung von Grenzen Zielen
wie sie wohl in jeder Form von Methodik
und geregelten unterrichten enthalten
sind
Hybride Unterrichtsmodelle blendet
learning Szenarien und das inverted
classroom-modell beruhen auf Regeln die
eingehalten werden müssen und ihre
Umsetzung bedarf gezielter Vorbereitung
Grenzen geben dabei Strukturen
Strukturen etablieren Stabilität und
Stabilität sorgt für Situationen in
denen geschützt und konzentriert gelernt
werden kann
denken Sie etwa an die didaktische
Bedeutung von Ritualen in der Lehre oder
auch darüber hinaus das Agieren in
sozialen Arrangements hat etwa den
positiven Effekt dass sich bei den
Lernenden eine gewisse
erwartungssicherheit entwickeln kann sie
wissen prinzipiell was auf sie zukommt
wenn Sie unsere Lehrveranstaltungen
besuchen und können sich durch diese
Verlässlichkeit entspannen das sorgt für
eine Entlastung des Arbeitsgedächtnisses
und für eine Angst für ein angenehmes
Lernklima
Grenzen haben also einen durchaus
positiven und konstruktiven Sinn in der
Lehre den wir auch in einer Diskussion
über die Benennung des Titels für das
Symposium bemerkt haben kurzfristig
kamen aufgrund des Begriffs nämlich
Zweifel auf denn Grenzüberschreitungen
sind nicht immer erwünscht sondern
können auch ernsthafte Probleme
markieren das bringt Vorwürfe zum
Ausdruck wie das kann er oder sie doch
nicht machen damit wird definitiv eine
Grenze überschritten
denken ließe sich dabei zum Beispiel an
die wichtige Grenze zwischen dem
Interesse an einem professionellen
Lehrern Setting und privaten Interessen
von Lehrenden und Lernenden die es zu
trennen gilt
ganz grundsätzlich stellen natürlich
positive rechtsgesetze solche Grenzen da
die natürlich auch in der
Unterrichtssituation zu gelten haben
darüber hinaus gibt es aber gerade für
Unterrichtssituationen noch unzählige
andere Regeln die unser Verhalten in
einem erwünschten Sinne begrenzen
Hinweise darauf geben etwa die
Beurteilungen von Lehrenden aus der
Sicht von Schülerinnen und Schülern die
Frage nach guten Lehrerinnen oder
Lehrern lassen in den Antworten zwei
beurteilungsdimensionen erkennen die
Herzmann und König so zusammenfassen ich
zitiere das sogenannte love Theme das
miterlebter emotionaler Wärme der
Lehrkraft umschrieben wird und das
masteriesleben dass die Wahrnehmung von
fachlichen Können die Herstellung eines
qualitätsvollen Unterrichts durch die
Lehrperson Disziplin sowie
Durchsetzungsvermögen der Lehrkraft
beinhaltet
es lässt sich also festhalten dass ganz
allgemein bereits das Streben nach einem
guten Unterricht etwa ein Hinblick auf
das Verhalten der beteiligten Grenzen
erfordert die es zu wahren gilt die uns
interessierenden Grenzüberschreitungen
haben offensichtlich eine erste Grenze
zu diesen Grenzen die es nicht zu
überschreiten sondern zu wahren gilt es
geht also nicht darum alle Grenzen
aufzuheben sondern nur diejenigen deren
Aufhebungen eine Verbesserung für die
Lehre versprechen
auf die Frage welche Grenzen wir also
überschreiten sollen wäre die Antwort
eben jene die einen guten Unterricht
eher hindern als fördern
ohne jetzt in die normativen Kriterien
des Guten Unterrichts tiefer
einzusteigen scheinen sich aus den
Beispielen dazu bereits zwei positive
Kriterien ableiten zu lassen
es geht um Grenzen die durch neue
Methoden und oder die damit verbundenen
technischen Möglichkeiten überwunden
werden können also Machbare Grenzen
Überschreitungen und es geht um Grenzen
die sich nicht jemand bewusst und aus
Gründen für einen guten Unterricht
gesetzt hat sondern die gerade deswegen
hinderlich sind weil sie unreflektiert
und konventionell Fortbestehen also
wünschenswerte Grenzüberschreitungen
als Lehrende sollen wir grenzen genau
dann überschreiten wenn wir sie uns
nicht bewusst für eine gelingende Lehr
Lernsituation selbst gesetzt haben diese
Grenzüberschreitungen sind es die eben
jenen beschriebenen Gewinn neuer
kreativer Möglichkeiten für die Lehrerin
Aussicht stellen
Machbare und wünschenswerte
Grenzüberschreitungen eröffnen uns neue
Wege die versprechen den Unterricht und
das Lernen zu optimieren hierhin scheint
mir der Grund für den normativen
Anspruch gegeben zu sein weil diese Art
Grenzüberschreitungen Potenzial für
gelingenden Unterricht enthalten sollen
wir sie umsetzen
warum dieses Grenzen überschreiten
vielleicht bereits selbst als ein
Kriterium gelingenden Unterrichts
gesehen werden kann dafür lässt sich die
bekannte hetty-studie erklären anfügen
sie hat eindrücklich auf die Bedeutung
und Wirksamkeit von absichtsvollen
Interventionen aufmerksam gemacht mit
denen Lehrpersonen des Lehren und Lernen
in ihrem Unterricht zu verbessern suchen
und durch die sie auch gewünschte
Effekte nachweisen lassen
in Hinsicht auf den Wert der von mir
beschriebenen Grenzüberschreitungen
lässt sich der von ihm durchgeführten
Argumentation für die Sichtbarkeit von
Lehrern und lernen folgende Beschreibung
über den Vorteil von Innovationen
anfühlen ist ein recht langes Zitat
deswegen habe ich es mitgebracht sie
können gerne mitlesen
die Botschaft lautet dass es nicht nur
darum geht innovativ zu sein sondern das
wenn Lehrpersonen Innovationen einführen
wir aus dem lernen was den Unterschied
ausmacht
wenn wir innovativ Handeln sind wir
aufmerksamer dafür was funktioniert und
was nicht
wir suchen nach Gegenargumenten wir
versuchen jegliche beabsichtigten und
unbeabsichtigten Auswirkungen ausfindig
zu machen und wir achten besonders
darauf welche Effekte die Innovationen
auf die Outcast haben in diesen
Situationen werden die Lehrpersonen zu
lernenden in Bezug auf ihre eigenen
Effekte
bei jeder Innovation erfolgt eine
bewusste Konzentration auf ihre
Umsetzung und ihre Effekte es gibt ein
bestimmtes Ausmaß an Herausforderungen
und eine Hochschätzung des Feedbacks es
ist entscheidend das Lehrpersonen aus
dem Erfolg oder Misserfolg ihre
Interventionen lernen
Lehrpersonen die in Bezug auf ihre
eigenen Effekte in die Rolle der
Lernenden gehen haben als Lehrpersonen
den größten Einfluss auf die Erhöhung
der Lernleistung ihrer Schülerinnen und
Schüler Zitat ein
das scheint mir zum einen eine gute
Beschreibung der Grenzüberschreitungen
zu sein Innovationen nach denen wir für
einen gelingenden Unterricht suchen und
zudem auch ein guter Grund dafür warum
wir sie als Lehrende vornehmen sollen es
geht um Innovationen die uns selbst im
Unterricht wach halten eben jene
Situationen die uns selbst zu
Entdeckerinnen werden lassen was von dem
versuchten funktioniert woran kann ich
das erkennen lässt sich das von den
Studierenden bestätigen was kann ich
beim nächsten Mal verbessern
beim Grenzen reflektieren und
überschreiten geht es nicht um das in
Frage stellen aller bestehenden
Strukturen für den Unterricht sondern es
geht darum selbst dafür zu sorgen etwas
Neues erblicken zu können durch das wir
als Unterrichtende Weiterlernen können
das Überschreiten konventioneller
unreflektierter und in Hinsicht auf eine
gute Unterrichtssituation sinnloser
Grenzen ermöglicht es uns bewusst in die
Rolle des Lernenden zu gehen und das
kann selbst als ein Kriterium für die
Steigerung der Lernleistung angesehen
werden auf diesen empirischen Beleg
machthetti insbesondere aufmerksam
damit habe ich versucht meine erste
Frage zu beantworten Grenzen sollen dann
überschritten werden wenn diese
Überschreitung etwas für den Unterricht
Positives mit sich bringt als so etwas
Positives kann die Rolle des Lehrenden
als Lernenden angeführt werden die immer
dann eingenommen wird wenn Lehrpersonen
innovativ handeln was Sie tun wenn Sie
Machbare und wünschenswerte Grenzen
überschreiben
ich komme zu meiner zweiten Frage warum
stellt die Lehrer Persönlichkeit für
Grenzüberschreitungen ein notwendiges
Kriterium
dass die lehrpersönlichkeit kein
hinreichendes Kriterium sein kann lässt
sich leicht einsehen denn natürlich
braucht es für die beschriebenen
Grenzüberschreitungen strukturelle
Bedingungen es müssen beispielsweise
Informationen zu technischen
Möglichkeiten auffindbar sein die Zeit
für eine solche Weiterbildung muss
aufgebracht werden können und
schließlich die Mittel zur Umsetzung
vorhanden sein
ohne diese Faktoren in ihrer Bedeutung
zu schmälern erscheint mir aber doch
letztlich die jeweilige Lehrperson als
zentrale Instanz für das einschlagen und
das Gehen dieser neuen Wege denn sie ist
es welche bestehende Grenzen wahrnimmt
und hinterfragt die Möglichkeiten
innerhalb der gegebenen
Rahmenbedingungen reflektiert und den
Mut die Kreativität und das Engagement
aufbringt sind der eigenen Praxis
umzusetzen
mit dem Blick auf Eigenschaften der
einzelnen Lehrpersonen lässt sich
vielleicht der bisweilen wahrgenommene
schleppende Einsatz von innovativen
Lehrmethoden erklären also etwa warum an
einer Fakultät zwar alle Dozierenden
fachlich über vergleichbare Kompetenzen
verfügen und zudem denselben Zugang zu
technischen Mitteln besitzen aber es
dennoch nur vereinzelt zu den vorhin
genannten Grenzüberschreitungen kommt
in meinem Fachgebiet theoretische
Philosophie stellen unterrichtsformate
die asynchrone und synchrone lehrphasen
etwa durch die Bereitstellung einer
Moodle Lernumgebung ansprechend umsetzen
noch eine kleine Innovation dar
für mich persönlich waren die ersten
Onlinekurse und Seminare gegenüber der
Lehre in Präsenz ebenfalls eine
Grenzüberschreitung die eine gewisse
Herausforderung darstellte mit der ich
mich nicht immer wohl gefühlt habe bei
der ich aber viel gelernt habe
man kann sich also fragen ob es
abgesehen von äußeren Zwängen wie sie
etwa die pandemische Lage mit sich
gebracht hat einer gewissen Eigenschaft
bedarf einer Persönlichkeitsstruktur um
sich Grenzüberschreitungen vorzunehmen
und sie auch umzusetzen und ob sie
vielleicht sogar ein notwendiges
Kriterium dafür ist
bei der Lehrer Persönlichkeit handelt es
sich wie in der Überschrift von meinem
Beitrag bereits angedeutet um eine
komplexe unterrichtsvariable der
persönlichkeitsansatz stellt die
Erforschung über Personenmerkmale von
Lehrenden in den Vordergrund und fragt
in Hinsicht darauf nach Unterschieden
des pädagogischen Einflusses und des
lehrerfolgs
damit verbunden sind etwaige
Schwierigkeiten etwa die Frage ob
eigenschaftskonstellationen als stabil
oder veränderbar angesehen werden müssen
wie man Befunde über sie empirisch
absichern kann und wie aussagekräftig
sie dann letztlich überhaupt für den
Lehrberuf sind
oftmals in der hobene Befunde wenig
konsistent und erlauben kein
allgemeingültiges Bild der guten oder
erfolgreichen Lehrkraft abzuleiten eher
erlauben Sie einige
persönlichkeitsvariablen und deren
mindestausprägungen als notwendige
Bedingungen eines erfolgreichen
lehrerhandels festzustellen
so zeigen etwa im Bereich der
temperamentsdimensionen als gut
beurteilte nährpersonen zum Beispiel
regelmäßig hohe Werte in emotionaler
Stabilität
Freundlichkeit Verträglichkeit und
tätigkeitsdrang Tatkraft
wie aussagekräftig diese allgemeinen
Merkmale dann als erklärende Kriterien
für gute Lehre oder sogar als Voraussage
über eine etwaige eigenen für den
nährberuf wirklich sind bleibt
dahingestellt dieselben Eigenschaften
benötigen schließlich auch andere
Berufsgruppen wie Krankenpfleger
Ärztinnen Politiker oder Profimannschaft
Sportler
letztlich wurde der
persönlichkeitsansatz von anderen
Forschungsansätzen abgelöst die stärker
auf die unterrichtsinteraktionen und die
darin enthaltenen Ursache
Wirkungsbeziehungen fokussieren wie
Herzmann und König über den
persönlichkeitsansatz dementsprechend
zusammenfassen verschwindet damit jedoch
nicht die Frage nach der Lehrer
Persönlichkeit und ihre Bedeutung als
unterrichtskriterien ich zitiere die
Suche nach dem geheimnisvollen Lehrer
gehen oder der angeborenen lehrbegabung
muss vor dem Hintergrund der Forschung
zu Lehrer Persönlichkeit im Sinne eines
allerklärungsanspruchs allerdings
aufgegeben werden das bedeutet im
Umkehrschluss jedoch nicht das
Persönlichkeitsmerkmale keinen Einfluss
auf die Qualität von Unterricht oder
etwa die Lernvoraussetzungen von
Lehrpersonen haben
aktuelle rahmenmodelle zu Beschreibung
von Unterrichtsqualität oder zu
Beschreibung und Erklärung
professioneller Kompetenz von
Lehrkräften nehmen den Faktor Lehrer
Persönlichkeit durchaus auf
wenn die Lehrer Persönlichkeit letztlich
zwar ein wichtiges Kriterium für
Lernerfolge darstellt darauf gibt auch
die bereits erwähnte hettichstudie
Hinweise aber sich diese nicht auf
bestimmte mehr oder weniger stabile
Eigenschaften reduzieren lässt worin
besteht sie dann
Ludwig Haag und Doris Streber sind in
ihrem Buch 2020 Lehrer Persönlichkeit
dieser Frage nach dem guten Lehrer oder
der guten Lehrerin
in verschiedenen Perspektiven
nachgegangen und zur einführenden
Definition grenzen Sie die Person als
Bezeichnung für jeden Menschen von der
Persönlichkeit als ich zitiere
allgemeine Bezeichnung für die
Gesamtheit der jeweils verwirklichten
Möglichkeiten einer Person
ab Gesamtheit der jeweils verwirklichten
unter Persönlichkeit wird das Ergebnis
oder der momentane Stand eines selbst
getätigten Bildungsprozesses verstanden
eine Persönlichkeit hat man nicht und
man wird auch nicht von einer anderen
Person zu einer Persönlichkeit gebildet
zumindest nicht direkt dazu wird der
Psychologe Wilhelm Karl Arnold zitiert
nicht ich bilde Dich viel mehr bilde ich
mich heraus im Umgang in der
Auseinandersetzung in der unplanenbahn
existenziellen Begegnungen mit dir du
Mitmensch dessen du nun mein ich ist
auch wenn hier eine existenzielle und
sehr allgemeine Sicht auf das Lernen
voneinander eingenommen wird zeigt sich
das Persönlichkeit nicht deskriptiv
verstanden wird wie etwa das
Vorhandensein spezifischer Merkmale oder
charakterlicher Dispositionen sich
beobachten lassen und beschrieben werden
Persönlichkeit stellt ein normatives
Ziel dar dass ideal dass sich selbst
bildenden und selbstverantwortlichen
Menschen wie es aus dem deutschen
Idealismus als Blütezeit der klassischen
Bildung stammt
mit diesem Verständnis von
Persönlichkeit führt uns die Frage nach
der Lehrer Persönlichkeit direkt hinein
in die grundsätzlichen Überlegungen was
das eigentliche Ziel von Bildung sein
kann oder soll aber ohne unsieren zu
verlieren lässt sich dadurch ein Aspekt
für die konkrete Lehre die uns heute
interessiert mitnehmen denn die paradoxe
Beschreibung der Selbstbildung durch
interpersonale Interaktion deutet auf
ein Spezifikum jeder Lehrtätigkeit hin
und zwar auf die Erziehungsfunktion
jede Lehrkraft ist neben
Wissensvermittler auch erzielen
während Unterricht sich mit Begriffen
wie Wissen Kompetenzen und Fertigkeiten
im schreiben lassen so Haag und Streber
richte Erziehung den Blick auf die
personale Ganzheit des Gegenübers also
die Persönlichkeit der Schüler
über das personale Engagement wird die
Lehrkraft ein Vorbild für die Schüler
wie es Tag und Streber nennen oder
zumindest zu einem Beispiel wie ich es
formulieren würde in dieser Perspektive
lässt sich ein berufsspezifisches
Kriterium für Lehrende abhalten die
Lehrer Selbstbildung
denn so stießen Haag und Streber ihre
Analyse zu Lehrer Persönlichkeit sich um
einen nachahmenswertes Modellverhalten
zu bemühen bedeutet möglicherweise mehr
als in anderen Berufen auf sich selbst
zu schauen darauf wenn man ist
Tiere es sind eher selbstkompetenzen als
Charakterunterschiede die dem Einzelnen
im Alltag zu bestehen und zu meistern
helfen hinter allen Fertigkeiten
Kompetenzen steht ein steuerndes und
lenkendes ich das darf man Lehrer
Persönlichkeit nennen
ein steuerndes und lenkendes ich zu sein
wenn das die Lehrer Persönlichkeit
darstellt dann ist sie ein notwendiges
Kriterium für die grenzüberschreitende
Lehrer denn wie in dem ersten Teil
meines Vortrags gezeigt sollen gerade
konventionelle unreflektierte Grenzen
überschritten werden
mit meinem kleinen Beitrag über Grenzen
und Lehrer Persönlichkeit geht es mir
also nicht darum zu sagen die einen sind
bessere Lehrer oder Lehrerinnen als die
anderen weil sie eben bestimmte
Eigenschaften mitbringen und deswegen so
oder so geworden sind
ich möchte darauf aufmerksam machen dass
wir selbst beeinflussen können gute
Lehrer und Lehrerinnen zu werden indem
wir uns stetig das Bilden ich denke man
ist nicht eine gute Lehrerin oder ein
guter Lehrer weil man es einmal gelernt
hat sondern weil man sich aktiv dazu
entscheidet immer weiter zu lernen so
können wir zum Beispiel unsere
Selbstwirksamkeit trainieren und
weiterentwickeln indem wir uns etwa
bewusst an Grenzüberschreitungen
versuchen
Selbstwirksamkeit bedeutet die innere
Überzeugung zu haben schwierige oder
herausfordernde Situationen gut meistern
zu können und das aus eigener Kraft
heraus
wie ich denke ist das nur eine andere
Formulierung dafür ein steuerndes und
lenkendes ich zu sein und die eigenen
Möglichkeiten als Person zu einer
Persönlichkeit zu entwickeln
vielen Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit und
ich wünsche Ihnen allen viel Freude beim
Weiterlernen durch die nächsten
Grenzüberschreitungen